philosophy for our times is brought to
you in partnership with the new college
of the humanities a university level
college offering undergraduate and
postgraduate degrees in the heart of
London NCH pride themselves on offering
unprecedented access to a world-class
academic faculty philosophy students of
the college are taught by some of the
foremost scholars in the field and
one-to-one tutorials create a
personalized teaching experience choose
your major and minor for a unique
combined honours degree and study the
NCH diploma to widen your appreciation
of the world in ways you never thought
of before go to NC h london AC dot UK
for more information think better think
NC h hello and welcome to philosophy for
our times the podcast which brings you
the world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas this debate is going to
look at the question of morality the
best question of morality and politics
this week our speakers take on this
vexed question to find out what the
morality politics should stay separate
does history favor the left or the right
sodor politicians think they're in the
right so we want our politicians to take
moral positions and do we believe them
if they do if so does the history of
party favor elect on the right we find
out and see whether the left is reason
to claim the moral high ground taking on
this task in this heated debate we have
leader of the women's equality party
Sophie Walker Mail on Sunday columnist
Peter Hitchens a Labour MP and former
vicar Chris Bryant we love bringing this
podcast for free I want to continue to
do so for as long as possible
as such it would be great if you could
head over to iTunes today and give us a
rating or review
as this helps other people find us as
ever do get in touch and let us know
what you thought the episode make sure
you subscribe to never miss an episode
and check out the whole host of episodes
we have available now and get
downloading back now Isabelle Hilton
host this week's episode let's look at
the question of whether history morality
favor the left or the right which which
do you think it is Chris I I'm an ex
used to be a vicar so I suppose I ought
to be arguing that you know God favors
the left and I helped run the Christian
Socialist Movement for several years and
but I I think it's actually very dubious
whether you come from a Christian
perspective or any other to presume that
you have all of the moral high ground
you may have good arguments that are
based on ethical considerations but
handing out membership cards for any
political party to the individual
members of the Holy Trinity I think is a
mistake however my biggest anxiety at
the moment is that there is a version of
politics which is deliberately amoral
that is to say I think some people in
politics at the moment around the world
have decided that if you lie at least
forty percent will believe you so you
might as well have those forty percent
so you might as well lie I think that is
the fundamental assumption behind Donald
Trump I think it's the assumption behind
for instance President Putin in relation
to Salisbury it was deliberate that
nobody should believe them because that
was part of putting two fingers up to
Britain and I think that that is an
essential part of the way that Putin
does his politics I've just come back
from China and where I was on a visit
with the Foreign Affairs Committee and
we met with a member of the Politburo
you know one of the 25 men who runs
China and his whole political posture
was amoral it was just about the economy
nothing more than that and you know we
raised various other issues and he was
simply not interested so I would argue
that you do have to have a morality I
get a bit
worried about people on moral Crusades
because if you believe in yourself too
much and you don't have an element of
doubt there's a danger I think that you
become a demagogue the classic instance
of this is not political at all but a
friend of mine was driving me to a
by-election and I said you sure this is
the right route and he said I'm 100%
certain and I that's what worried me
because when somebody's a hundred
percent certain it seems to me they
haven't taken into consideration the
possibility that they might be wrong and
those are the most dangerous people of
all so a leak and he was wrong it was
robberies of course so a late bid for
the for the virtues of doubt and say I'm
an Anglican after all history morality
on the side of the left or the right
okay so I'm gonna have a go answering
the question so I think both sides often
I mean always lay claim to delivering
progress but from where I'm sitting I
suppose it's it's a plague on both
houses because both left and right the
morality that they present damages
women's lives and so long as we have
history books and morality lessons
written by men institutions ruled and
governed by men economic templates
written to the male experience I mean
Adam Smith is the ultimate right his
irony free declaration of man's
self-interested man while he sort of was
had his meals brought by his mother you
know basically this this is this for me
is the is the overarching issue which is
that both sides are bringing a morality
that doesn't see women so on the right
we've got a system that prizes family
values conservatism based on very narrow
and quite oppressive views about what
families should be so white middle-class
heteronormative but you but from that
position you can still support and pass
laws on for example gay marriage because
it follows views on the sanctity of
marriage and a sort of emulation of
heteronormativity if you like and from
the right the mark that sort of morality
allows women
to thrive when they fall within
conservative values so I'd this idea of
a meritocracy for example where women
can make it to be Prime Minister if
they're if they're just as good as men
if they try harder they can get further
and this declaration that you know the
right it does better for women because
they've had two female Prime Minister's
that sort of examining the idea that two
women in in two hundred years is
probably not that much of a meritocracy
but on the right it's when women fall
outside of that very narrow vision of
morality that women are punished so to
child limits on a child tax credit a
perfect example of furnishing families
that don't meet conservative values it's
black and Asian families the hardest
Runnymede trust I think yes in the
women's Budget Group sure that the
combination of cuts and changes to
universal credit would hit black women
the most leading the five thousand
pounds worth of a year on average
I know it's interesting because I think
then this strong moral attachment to
Family Values does mean that the right
can pass useful legislation that
recognizes for example violence against
women and girls criminalizing female
genital mutilation revenge porn the
bringing of the domestic abuse bill but
only because that violence is seen as
egregious to the morality of family and
as anomalous episodes rather than as a
result of structural inequality that
women experience and that's why the
forthcoming domestic violence bill is so
slim which is a huge disappointment
coming from Teresa mais government what
is good about it is that it makes abuse
in front of children and an aggravating
factor it strengthens family law courts
but there is no funding additional
funding ring-fenced funding protected
sustainable sufficient funding for the
services run by and for women living
with an escaping from male violence and
of course the right has presided over
austerity that has made poor women even
poorer disproportionately being paid for
by women eighty six percent of it has
been paid by women now on the left of
course we have as jeremy JC was saying
yesterday the left is the party of women
left as the party of equality i disagree
fundamentally with this because the left
has a structural analysis and a morality
that is limited very much to class
and particularly in this latest
incarnation can't see any oppression
that's not Western and capitalist and
that is why in the past example men on
the left of condoned FGM as a cultural
practice because they don't see the
oppression of black and Asian women by
black and Asian men it doesn't fit into
their structural class analysis the left
is obsessed with working-class men's
jobs jeremy corbyn's - this summer
though his made in britain brexit plan
that affirms his 50-year focus on
manufacturing which is frankly a slap in
the face to millions of women who
disproportionately employed in service
sector do you know what how the Treasury
classifies a woman her mother raising
two children and caring for an L an
elderly parent economically unproductive
economically inactive inactive and the
left doesn't have an answer to that
because it it ignores the vast amount of
work unpaid and low paid care work that
women do and I think you know we're
going to talk about morality of equality
we need I would expect labor not just to
want to nationalize everything from
where we store water to energy to Royal
Mail but actually to do something about
Social Care which has an 80% female
workforce and is absolutely on its knees
so yeah I mean the center-left has made
some progress particularly on
representation but in the 2015 election
it was a huge disappointment to me to
see the left did not make a case against
austerity despite it being evidence at
that point that women were
disproportionately paying for it it just
bargained with itself over how much more
of it we could take thank you does
history morality favor the left or the
right Chris is the next Vicar I'm a next
rots guest when I was the trotsky's of
course I had no morals at all which is
the whole point of it that you you you
set out to do what you thought was right
at the expense of anybody or anything
that got in your way and how they ever
been in the position to do it I would
have done terrible things to my
opponents on those grants because I
believed so profoundly that I was right
and one of the reasons why I am now
oddly enough in the same church is Chris
Bryant is because I decided to put a
stop to all that I didn't think it was
the
chitta MOT anymore to believe so
strongly that I was right that I could
even think of treating people as I would
have done had I successfully achieved
the Bolshevik Revolution which I sought
so actively in the 1960s and 1970s
so morality in politics seems to me to
be dangerous the other thing about
morality as it seems to me to be
increasingly as I get older and nearer
and nearest being dead that it seems to
me should be very much about yourself
and not about other people the best
definition of morality I ever came
across was morality is what you do when
you think nobody is looking and people
sometimes get quite shocked when I say
that and but it is it seems to me an
honest appreciation of what it's about
what politicians can do about morality
is they can quite often push people into
doing things they don't want to do
because they the politicians think those
things are right or they can stop people
from doing things that they would
otherwise like to do and my great beef
about this is that over the past 50 or
60 years almost every piece of
legislation social or economic has been
designed to make it harder for people
unless they're very rich to raise their
own children and particularly for women
to stay at home and bring up the next
generation rather than going out and
being waste lives I will I will say one
other thing that the left over that
period have tended to take the view
that's simply by holding the opinions
they have and being on the side of what
they term progress they are themselves
moral and that those who don't hold
their views which I don't themselves
amoral so I take for example the fact
that I happen to think that capital
punishment is sometimes justified in the
case of heinous murder now you can argue
about this with me and you can disagree
with me about it and I will happily take
you on but the reaction of most
self-described civilized persons in in
London to any suggestion of that kind is
to recoil like a salted snail from me as
a person because I am so evil that I
hold this view and this seems to me to
be a major problem in public discourse
you cannot really debate against anybody
who despises you
and I find that it's very difficult a
lot of the time to actually hold the
base because very rapidly the rules of
reason and logic and the the
presentation of fact in support are you
flies out of the window and it becomes
about who and what you are and that
seems to me to be a major problem with
almost all modern political discourse
the left think they're right and not
nearly that they think they're better
people
hmm well is that that brings us onto the
web you know will was encouraged by a
repentant sinner you've you've retreated
from your absolutist position of your
use but that does leave the question of
whether politics should or could be a
morality free zone so what is the role
of morality and politics well the less
morality the better in my view because
it tends to be very much directed these
days in in in one direction that is in
starting foreign wars in other people's
countries on the grounds that by doing
so you will make things better and
currently there is certainly in the
political class I'm not at all sure that
it's shared by the population a view
that we should actively intervene in the
Syrian crisis and first of all we are
already intervening how we buy subsidy
and secret activity we have long been
encouraging jihadists to rise up against
the Syrian government with catastrophic
consequences but secondly if we if we
went further and intervened more
directly this would prolong a hideous
war which has already killed huge
numbers of people and turn millions from
reasonably happy and content human
beings into homeless refugees and this
has all been done is pursued at the
moment and has universal support it
seems to me in the House of Commons on
the ground so that it would be moral for
us to intervene
just as the Iraq war was sold to us
basically on the moral grounds that we
would get rid of an evil dictator so and
the Libyan intervention again we were
getting rid of an evil dictator we
turned both countries into cauldrons of
blood and screams but that was all done
on the basis of moral beliefs which tend
to be utopian so I would be very much
against that form of morality and
politics in other matters say whether
discussing the education system or the
health service people should be a good
deal more willing unlike Chris Brandt's
unfortunate hundred percent driver a
good deal more willing to
recognize that they might not actually
be 100% right about the issue that would
be a moral thing to do so so crisply the
question of morality as as laid out by
Peter to be approached with caution and
uncertainly
if when delivered to be delivered with
competence I'm finding this really
difficult that I'm agreeing rather a lot
with him this is seriously alive this is
good I might have to get it's the first
time you've ever listened to what I say
to be fair it's mostly because you just
agreed with what I said earlier so but I
remember boys in politics but I will I
remember it's interesting there's a
debate about and the involvement of the
private sector in the NHS in Britain
right and I think many people on the
Left think that it's immoral somehow for
the including people in my own party to
think it's immoral for the private
sector to be involved in the NHS in any
shape or form
indeed I remember sitting on a panel in
Wales in Welsh Labour Party conference
and a leading figure in there Welsh
Assembly said this he said I will not
allow any involvement whatsoever the
private sector in the NHS in Wales and I
said what about opticians
well obviously opticians chemists well
obviously you obviously have chemists
and so it goes on I mean sometimes I
think people when they adopt absolutist
positions simply don't allow the the
light of you know facts and common sense
to come in but at the same time I mean I
disagree with Peter about Libya I didn't
vote for the Libyan adventurer I thought
it was misguided and wrong not
particularly on a moral argument there
was a moral argument which was being
made which was not about removing
Gaddafi it was actually about the fact
that there were I can't remember how
many people trapped and who were clearly
about to be killed by Gaddafi's forces
well then there was there was an alleged
massacre which was going to take place
in Benghazi and they were alleging
that's right anyway I think as they
didn't have any nuns they couldn't claim
they were being raped and as far as I
know no one was being my ideas were
being bayonetted but people really ought
to learn to be
careful about Patricia he probably under
ordinary with that however you know I'm
writing about the 1930s at the moment
and lots of people in Britain refused to
believe about the atrocities against the
Jews in the 1930s partly because they
thought that we should not have a moral
position on that whatsoever and if I
look at the three intervention of the
three countries we're in the Middle East
where there's been a dispute over the
last few years so Iraq Libya and Syria
and non-intervention predominantly non
intervention in Syria has led to far
more people being displaced many
millions and destabilizing other
countries in the region it's a miracle
that Lebanon has not collapsed into
civil unrest and many more people being
killed now it's not the time but when
the the the moral case for intervention
goes back to the responsibility to
protect that was a shift between the
state as the kind of predominant subject
of care in the UN to the people and that
strikes me as a you know a moral
argument that one could defend whether
how you act on it is another issue but
in terms of its morality surely the
treatment everything to make a factual
point I mean the Washington Post says
and I think they've we could reasonably
assume they're right that the CIA's
budget for intervention on the side of
jihadis in Syria has been roughly 1
billion dollars a year that's not non
intervention the West has been
intervening outside the Gulf countries
very heavily in Syria ever since
what is it 20 2011 2012 particularly in
supplying arms and equipment and
training and all kinds of other
facilities to the jihadists who have
been fighting against the Assad State
and I think there that has been in where
there's not only no such thing as no
intervention very strong use but again
you haven't quite answered the question
whether you think the responsibility to
protect is a justifiable moral position
right now that executed but all of this
comes down to Machiavelli right which
says that you just the politics the the
justification of what you do in politics
is about the ends justifying them
and I think actually what we keep doing
is converting we keep roughly what he
said yeah we keep completing morality
and human rights here actually is what
is going on a lot of the time and I
think the morality does inconsistently
govern politics but I think where we see
it consistently as Peter points out is
the case for war which is always being
presented as you know somebody's moral
idea versus somebody else's idea of
which human rights who should be
protected but the one thing that we that
I think my big beef with this is that
the thing that we very very rarely look
at more closely is the constant capacity
that people are given to vote against
women's human rights women's
particularly reproductive rights on the
grounds of a vote on conscience and you
can sit here and talk about war and but
like every single day we make decisions
about women's reproductive rights that
are not based on human rights but are
based on somebody else's version of
morality and and it's happening on the
right the Conservatives want support
women's rights particularly one
supporting I was in Ireland women's
rights because of this horrific deal
that they've done with the DUP and on
the Left Stella Creasy is doing
brilliant work but she her par she's not
backing her up labour doesn't have a
policy to back it up they should be
pushing this policy but broadly speaking
but I'm talking about party position as
opposed to individuals I let's go back
to the question of the of the of the
left's claim to to the moral high ground
you I mean would you would you support
that do you think this is tenable at
this point and do you think it's doing
the left any good in in an era where as
as indeed we've discussed already in
this in this in this conversation the
question of how you deliver politics is
as much is as important as the moral
basis from which you begin well I think
the left is many different things and at
the moment in politics the left is quite
uncertain where it stands not only in
this country but in many other places I
think so
justice is one of the least attractive
things in politics personally it's one
of the reasons I never really cared for
Simon Hughes very much right sorry Simon
Hughes you have a view on Simon Hughes
if you like I would like to talk about I
mean I'd like to talk about the left's
sense of itself as being the you know
the obsession with morality if you like
the best at the left is the better
people and actually the the damage that
I see this doing in terms of getting
better all-round outcome so I mean I saw
this too up close when I campaigned in
Shipley so the general election 2017 the
women's equality parties number one
target seat was Shipley where Phillip
Davis MP sits I don't know if anybody in
here knows Phillip Davis basically he
believes in equality of opportunity but
not equality of outcome he filibustered
against the Istanbul convention bill to
end violence against women and girls
because it didn't mention men in the
title he has suggested that people with
disabilities should be paid less he is
somebody who stands for everything that
I think is wrong in politics and I went
and moved up to Shipley to contest him
for eight weeks I was our number-one
target seat the Labour Party was furious
absolutely furious I spent about seven
weeks of that campaign fighting with
labor rather than actually managing to
land blowers on Phillip because the
Labor Party were absolutely outraged
that we would be there getting in the
way splitting their vote as they saw it
and they spent huge amounts of time
trolling me abusing me fighting me
instead of getting out and I'm fighting
Phillip in a seat which they hadn't made
a target seat but the whole of that
campaign was characterized by sense that
this is ours this is our seat we are the
better people if he is a body then we
are the only people that can take him on
and what we were trying to do was to
mobilize one candidate whether it was me
or anybody else against him and and and
it was a really lost opportunity I'm
delighted to say that as a result of me
running and Shapley labor subsequently
made it a target see and has
subsequently chosen a woman to fight it
right
so that's an example of the left
claiming immoral hike it spent the week
yeah they spent the whole election
claiming the moral high ground which
basically meant having a pop at me
instead we're having a pop at you saying
you never claim the moral high ground
I'm saying that I was there as a I was
there to do what our party sets out to
do which is to achieve women's equality
and the Labour Party which consistently
says it is the party of women's equality
it was more interested in fighting me
than making that a target seat but the
shipley has been a target seat it's a
marginal seat historically it's been
labour and Tory yeah the only party who
is likely to take the Tory out there is
labour and just as we've seen in
successive American elections when the
left splinters and gets all
self-righteous about each other and the
right wins but you see that's what
happened in Shipley who gave the seat to
the Tory person that you most don't want
to have not at all in fact what happened
was that we knocked on 31,000 doors we
got more people out to vote than ever
before and we halved his majority we
also brought it to the attention of
labour and you did Georgiy we have this
majority we we got the boat out for
eucharist right so let's not refight the
whole Shipley election forever
but you see women's equality is not
being self-righteous it's about it so it
is about saying we're tired of you
assuming that we will continue to wait
in line we are tired of you assuming
that we will keep voting for you until
you get around to us that is the self
righteousness of the left which is
leaving women behind and that's because
you're absolutely right it's my opinion
the strong opinion get the strong
impression I don't just think it's your
opinion you think you're absolutely
right I think the economy would do
better if 100 percent of the population
had a chance and I think the society
would do better if 100 percent of people
got a chance to share care and and you
know men could stay at home if they
wished all that I mean I just think that
we are working to templates that don't
work and I want to try something
different
could we invite you to lay out the moral
position of the right since we've had
the lesson is that morality is for
individuals but I do think that it's
getting very hard in a society with an
increasingly strong interfering state a
state which in my view intervenes very
much on behalf of of Commerce and
business to make people's lives more and
more subject to the needs of business
and whose cynical alliance with what I
think is now fourth stage feminism is
really all about getting as many women
into the workplace as cheap compliant
wage slaves as it could possibly manage
I think this particular cynical Alliance
has done enormous damage to personal and
private life in our country I think that
the basis of freedom in any country is
private life and I think the basis of
private life is strong families and I
think that both Commerce and the state
dislike strong families intensely and
want to get rid of them and so we see
this desert of 0 as contracts and and
low-wage jobs in which nobody can afford
what would what a normal British
working-class family of the 1950s 60s
and 70s would have seen as normal a one
income being enough to live on so we all
have to go out and slave for next to
nothing for global corporations and this
somehow has
into alliance with with the cause which
considers itself to be feminist I do not
disagree with anything in anything at
all in Virginia Woolf a Room of One's
Own I think it's an absolutely perfect
statement of the feminist case I don't
think that feminism was ever about the
destruction of family life or the
regimental of women into wage slavery as
it has become and I think interested in
the in the in the welfare of women it
wouldn't go down this road against the
politics of interest rather than a
politics morality I'm supposed to go
haven't you just made the case against a
politics which is defined by interest
rather than with immoral I don't say I'm
saying that a policy which which
presents itself as moral is in fact is
in fact a policy of commercial interest
and the pursuit of power which is so and
very often the case and this is the this
is what idealist politics is about it
presents hard commercial and political
interests as a moral case and people are
fooled by it and then they find
afterwards that they were full so would
you grace a member of the Labour Party a
party so we are just that wasn't in
doubt it was kind of where to position
the Labour Party at this point yeah
indeed members of the Labour Party like
you I mean the the the would you see a
major moral difference between the left
and the right in politics in this
country at this point I find it
difficult to generalize for the Labour
Party at the moment I mean I think to be
honest I know well I mean I think it's a
very serious point which is at the
moment in certainly in parliamentary
politics and that's not the whole of
politics but it's part of it the two
major parties are fundamentally divided
down the middle and one of the things
I've argued for a long time in favour of
proportional representation and simply
because I think the kind of battle that
we have about Shipley and is played out
because we have a majoritarian system
where it's first-past-the-post and
actually I'd much prefer it if people
were able to vote for the party that
they really believe in you would
probably see the parties splinter at
more
the Labour Party is in effect a
coalition between socialists and Social
Democrats and the Tory party between
cultural Patriots and economic
pragmatists and those two we will
probably be better off in politics we
probably had politicians telling more
truths and if you had a system which was
more multifaceted but that's not the
situation we've got at the moment so
what I tried to do in my own political
life is there are things that I believe
in for me it is an article of faith for
instance and that we should remain in
the European Union I I was a remainer I
remain a remainer I'll remain a remainer
until my dying day and and but I know
that for some other people it's just a
question of how you play out the next
few months and and and that is that is
quite a tough sort of place to be in as
it happens I also normally believe in
compromise if I'm in a room of 10 people
are disagreeing I try to be the person
who's trying to build to compromise
that's not an answer to your question
probably it's just me exploring why I
find present-moment
politics really very tough yes I think I
think you get a lot of support on that
position and I think also that you know
you've touched on the state of current
politics in terms of the of the of the
incoherence of political parties in this
country which had is a very confusing
position at the same time in terms of
the wider debate and and Peter mentioned
this in his opening remarks is that the
extreme positions that are taken in the
wider public debate make political
discussion and the compromise which you
you've embraced as a as an important
part of politics very difficult right
now and and I don't know Peter if you'd
like to given given that which i think
is pretty evident that politics that the
the the wider discussion of politics has
become extremely hostile and unpleasant
what's the future of that debate how can
we move politics on from the the
disqualification of somebody's views on
the basis of the perception of their
position and their moral belief
well I think it's too late and I'm
afraid that for about 20 years now from
my own position originally believing
that I could do some good
I put deliberately in front of people on
the left such as Chris and many others a
series of objections to the policies
they were pursuing whether they were
policies on education whether there were
policies on crime and punishment whether
there were policies on immigration I
said these policies are ignore so
completely the real position and the
plight particularly of the poor in our
country that you are storing up for
yourselves a great rebellion against you
which will be much less nice than I am
and you don't think I
you don't think I'm nice so you wait and
see and I said this and I said this and
I got nothing but scorn and rejection
and I could live with that personally
you know I my own life is blessed it
doesn't make any real difference to me
and I should be dead soon so the
consequences oh it don't matter very
much but the truth was that I was
genuinely trying to argue with the left
who had it seemed to me taken control of
politics the Academy the civil service
and the law they had a responsibility to
listen otherwise they were risking
something this was Vemma and they were
risking something horrible afterwards
and now they have Donald Trump and they
don't realize it was their fault and now
they have the referendum result and they
don't realize it was their fault so this
day they have not understood that it was
their own behavior which led to these
consequences and the I hate the division
of this country at the moment over the
European issue on which I am NOT what
most people expect I very much favor the
Norway option I refused to take any part
in the referendum campaign I didn't vote
in it and people who also matically
assume because I'm right-wing that I'm
Jacob Riis MOG it's not so there are
other there are other positions which
one can take them and I regret
enormously and I look looking back at
the history of my own country I can
think only of the periods of Munich and
Suez as comparable times when people
genuinely stopped speaking to each other
which is the disaster for civil society
but it's not my fault it's your fault
for saying no attention whatever to the
incessant attempts by by
such as neither safety you've got this
wrong you're ignoring really important
people you're ignoring the poor in this
country and the lives that they're
living and and you will eventually pay
the price and now you're paying it it's
like only pleasure in life my only
pleasure in in public life say I killed
I am the chief of the i-told-you-so
industry and all my books on the site
which say I told you so really no no no
we're clear on that sure I get something
out of it so I mean I think this is
where I cycled back round against the
beginning to say you know plague on both
houses again because like we got where
we were because neither side was able to
offer a vision brexit was two options
which were both crap you know you either
had fat Faraj harking back to a sort of
golden age of empire and the 1950s model
of you know where sort of women knew
their place this is a guy who was like a
city trader and mep for 15 years he
swapped his his cigars for cigarettes
and his wine for beer and he pretended
he was a man of the people and then on
the other side we had the sort of same
kabbalah box bridge man who'd failed in
their campaign to get britain into the
euro and sort of sent out distress
signals from the financial times and
people wanted progress and progress was
not an offeror so they picked change and
a huge number of those people were women
because actually the poorest people in
this country are women two-thirds of the
poorest people in this country are women
and brexit lets everybody down on all
sides and i think that i mean i also
think there is a different version of
feminism believe it or not Peter that
isn't a choice between staying at home
or being a cheap wage slave it's one
where you actually invest in social
infrastructure that's never ever ever
been done equal investment in social
infrastructure as in construction yields
more jobs higher tax revenues lower
benefit payments so there is a third way
and it evolves women and I think ok can
i but I also the last thing I'd like to
say in terms of morality is that what
we've ended up in along with this sort
of morality is certainty and certainty
is a truly terrible terrible thing in
politics we need more people to be
asking questions and we need an honesty
I would rather follow somebody
in fact I would rather be the person
saying I don't know let's figure it out
together than to follow somebody who
says I'm stronger than him come with me
and we are heading very quickly into
that nihilism and I find that really
frightening so are you are you saying
that the women's party is offering a
politics that is less polarized
I'm certain it's well it's not the
women's party it's the women's equality
permitting because the point of it is
that we are building a template that
creates equality by looking at it
through feminism and that that version
of building for equality actually makes
life better for everyone and is that a
politics of less polarization less moral
certainty I think it's about we have to
get away from the binary of left and
right and I don't buy that I don't mean
some sort of poncey new center ground
party funded by the men that got kicked
out of all the other parties it's just
cheap shabby politics that is I'm sorry
I I I respect many of the opinions but I
don't respect the way they're delivered
but I think that is nasty politics I
think it is large I think I think it is
men with power assuming that they can go
away and start another party and that's
a huge assumption it's the same people
it's the same money it's the same
opinions and what I'm saying is very
very it's it's women and people who have
been left behind watching the same
people with the same opinions and the
big pots of money making politics that
works for them and it's very frustrating
I know the loss of polarization here but
I I represent I represent one of the
poorest constituencies in the country
and the and the kind of things that and
think so politics in Wales are slightly
different because we have a Welsh
Assembly which runs its politics in a
different way from the government in
Westminster but that the issues I know
on the doorstep thirty years ago if you
worked as a builder you'd be able to buy
the house that you built if you work 40
days 40 ask 40 days a week 40 hours a
week today you would not stand a chance
of being able to do that even in a place
like the Rhonda
warehouse prices are much lower than
they are anywhere like here and at the
moment the majority of the people in the
Rhonda who are living in poverty and
have to rely on food banks are in work
so yes of course I think there's a
morality about all of this
I think that's immoral that we are the
sixth richest country in the world and
we have we don't spend enough on our
public services to be able we don't even
spend enough on and allow people to have
legal aid anymore to be able to defend
the benefits as disabled people that
they should be entitled to which is why
lots of people are now living in even
worse abject poverty and than in other
countries in Europe and so of course I
think there's a moral argument to this
but I have to fit that with the fact
that we have a parliamentary system in
this country which is based on
first-past-the-post
which delivers two big parties I'm not
in favor of people splitting off from
the Labour Party because in the end we
have a first past the post system and
you will either have a Tory government
or a Labour government come the next
general elections and you've got to get
used to it I'd love to change every
element of the system the House of Lords
I don't understand I don't believe
anybody should have got to get used to
it why should we have to get used to it
so that you can change it but you're not
but we're not there's nothing to vote
for there's nothing to vote for one of
the reasons we've got we offer joint
membership we're the only political
party that offers joint membership you
can join us and be a member of any other
political party apart from the BNP you
don't want you and the point is that we
have got to start being more
collaborative we're looking at joint
membership we're looking at joint
candidacy we are trying to do different
collaborative ways of working because
you can't just stand and say you know
you have to put up with this changing
but the only way you can change it is by
changing the system and you can only
change the system by winning thank you
proposition of greater collaboration as
opposed to polarization and position
taking and would you please join me in
thanking so people could subscribe and
thank you so much for listening for this
episode of philosophy for our times this
podcast was brought to you by the
Institute of Arts and ideas it was
hosted by me and Carrie and I guess this
week for Sofie Walker Peter Hitchens and
Chris Brian's as ever please do make
sure that you're subscribed to the
podcast to make sure you never miss an
episode
cliff to iTunes and give us a rating and
review as this helps other people find
us and of course tune in next week for
more debates and talks the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
institute of arts and ideas at iai
TV
you